hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the four horsemen an
amnesia custom story that is incredibly
highly rated by a lot of people I think
it had a 9.6 if I'm not mistaken anyway
your name is Alastair you're a 19th
century researcher who has devoted your
life to the study of the Four Horsemen
on hearing reports of their arrival on
earth you realize that you may have the
knowledge to save mankind from
annihilation how would I hear reports
about it and I just know happen to know
that the things that I'm studying are
coming down to earth from my alien
sources up above I'll be able to solve
this mystery in no time cuz I'm out of
stare star alistair it is the 24th of
May 1841 yes after several days finally
I'm a brother Stein man yes it is here
that I predicted the opening of the
Horseman's portal the correct the portal
must have opened days before I arrived
whatever station I witnessed or
suggested the four have already left
around mmm now they write Earth's
landscapes destroy all life till now for
I can put a stop to their endless
slaughter that is all signed will all
the time he needs the manor lies an open
portal into the realm
I must enter it and find a means to
their end
oh man it's gonna be cool I already know
it's highly rated it's got new stuff in
it it's got custom stuff there was some
things in there that I didn't even
recognize oh my goodness I always get
giddy whenever I play a really good one
of these because I am these just what I
started with and then I take it in short
bits and I go in between them and then I
play it again I go oh it's gonna be fun
so let's get to it let's see I got a
lock it what's important the my pin hole
photograph of katherines somehow looking
at is this comes me so how did you
escape the devastation of the four
horsemen who's that just a flash forward
a flash back
I'm obviously incredibly rich and can
afford the mansion of a
multi-millionaire
excuse me you're here a little early I
haven't even soaked in the atmosphere of
this place so I need to teach you a
lesson sonny jim huh okay so that guy's
being a douche bag but I've got
tinderboxes here and I've got the will
to live now if only I could find tiny
bugs Tim how many people know but tiny
box Tim came from an amnesia custom
story a late-night drink it's one of my
favorites that ever happened dear lord
Rothstein
I regret to inform you that I am handing
in my notice the tools have been
returned to the outhouse in the
courtyard I would like to thank you for
your hospitality and I wish you well for
the future yours faithfully William
McNeal
well fine screw you is it the four
horsemen that drove you away from
service in my home that was the
groundskeeper by the way yeah nothing
but big bully boxes over here where's my
tiny box Tim oh man this game actually
this game mode or mod or whatever you
want to call it came out like a while
ago I don't even know how I overlooked
and I think it came out in 2013
early but I made me mistaken I have no
idea but either way I'm playing it right
now
and I'm very eager to see what it has in
store for me
hello some spooky scary monsters maybe
oh maybe the knocking was coming from up
here well then it's not particularly
dark but I'm assuming that's because
it's kind of light outside ah
that's interesting find something to
break down the barricade blocking off
access to part of the West Wing on the
first floor okay
oh I'm looking for the oh I can't climb
over that that looks lovely I'm oh this
isn't my mansion oh I'm a poor man I'm a
crazy researcher with a tinfoil hat
trying to figure out a way to be able to
go and stop the four horsemen you know
my other split personalities that ended
up brutally murdering everybody outside
I know I'm making a lot of sumption but
I played quite a few amnesia custom
stories in indie horror games I know all
the cliches but I'm assuming that a game
that was cliched wouldn't be as highly
rated exist one
the upper courtyard door you got it
sonny jim i'm on my way
why is it all so crackly here my gamma
was a little high it was a little too
bright in here I normally bright it for
you guys if it's a bit of a problem to
see I wanna get these true atmosphere of
this game and with it cuz I'm eager I'm
ready
hi bring this under the air can't move
alright I'll just fall over then go my
knee snap time hello Dallas
now what did I just experienced my sound
now Katherine Katherine no I thought
Katherine was a lady not a little girl
cuz I was assuming and I forgot that I
had a British accent I need to channel
my inner yamimash oh so you gonna be
like that huh
to the East Wing we go she held until if
she eventually tired late into the night
she slipped we're diving right into this
one okay not through there
I hear a rumbly okay
Oh see so why is it wet there uh-oh
unless I just peed my pants at that jump
scare oh no it wasn't even really
justice wind rustling through the
hallways you know the rushing wind from
this room out into the other room
why is there light coming from behind
there hello I'm trying to be very
observant about my surroundings I don't
want to miss anything and look like a
total doof I'm actually gonna turn the
gamma all the way down get some real
atmosphere going on you guys are gonna
be along for the ride even if I run out
of oil and don't know where the hell I'm
going you guys are gonna be here with me
right to the bitter end okay whoa that's
nothing
it was just a little girl crying for
some reason you taught me the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse decided to
haunt this place beforehand maybe I'm
just seeing my known nightmares it's
like that thing that does that thing
that does that you guys on I'm talking
about right the thing that makes you see
nightmares and whatnot lower car yard
that's exactly what I needed so glad
that I'm in the upper courtyard to be
able to find that no wait I'm over in
the East Wing
wait a minute I didn't get the key to
that like a machine he knew what he had
to do he didn't stop himself he
continued until he was ended oh this was
the courtyard outside that's right I
remember anybody oh yeah yeah smooth man
huh I haven't seen you in a while
oh hi there I'm a little jumpy
I will admit I got the volume cranked up
to maximum yeah that's normal I can't
remember the last time I saw two knights
of armor standing what did I do
you sicko
just as I was having a moment touching
the butt of this tattoo you decided
jump-scare me am I supposed to be able
to do anything with these guys not that
I want to know Scooby uh-oh well don't
see what the big deal is but maybe I
just said something horrible by taking
off their heads
hi friend you're naked okay bye
I'll be on my way then so they decide to
throw up poof rat me right away my
amnesia instincts tells me that the next
thing they throw it's not gonna be a
poof er because this is an actually good
one I did download this stuff no no
that's out of Hoover is it
block it myself all righty then that's
okay we're gonna be fine I'm just gonna
hide there I'm gonna hide under this one
unless they don't need a hi oh I'm
totally fine
I swear though I hear noises that I
don't normally hear oh that's just the
wind rustling through the trees good
good
ah good yes at least I have the crowbar
now so I can unblock the wreckage that
was in the way to get to the other area
taking the life of another to destroy
them but who is he was he taken drive I
don't know I'm a cool dude oh I get it
that's what's needed to do the thing
it's much darker in here now because I
turn the gamma back down ah so this is
what it truly was so now I need to go
back upstairs need to go over to the
other room and decide to open it up with
my bare hands
and maybe the minor addition of a
crowbar but mostly my bare hands got it
from playing enviro bear simulator I
need to actually be sparing about my
lanterns oh this is why the creepy
crawlies were in my brain it was
actually legitimately dark then wait oh
haha
you can faintly see Freeman engraved in
the handle a half-life 2 reference my
fav e are you then huh okay did I get it
back I did not get it back and
completely exploded into another
dimension maybe I'll find it on the
other side of this portal yeah they
someone lose an arm rats you hungry I
cooked one of you for a burger once
how's cool
oh there's a dead guy Oh with that that
was your arm oh no you have your arms
also you still have your junk which is
you know something not everyone gets
that privilege so you're lucky god old
amnesia music every time I load it back
up I always commented huh brings back
all these memories are the first time I
play this game and it's damn true it is
every single time I load it back up it's
like the first time I played it it's
awesome
is this such a cherished memory in my
mind I love it come on let me in anybody
anybody want to let me in okay never
mind
well fine I'll go down in the basement
alrighty then is that something that's
actually a thing okay so that's not the
poufy poop
we're gonna hide of course in here
they'll never find me in a closet it's
always been the pristine perfect
Fortress of Solitude what are you doing
out there
hello hi
are you leaving I've come back I just
want to get a good look at you
oh jeez ah coming back or he's out
leaving you who's coming back
come on buddy no no no you didn't hear
nothing well I guess it's time for me to
leave then huh
yeah about that I'll just be on my way
through the door you just caved in and
then I'll never ever bother you ever
again
as long as you promise to do the same to
me oh wait a minute what the hell is
this made it back to the beginning of
the area this is where I was before ah
so this is how you gonna play it so do I
need to come back this way er there's
some other direction that I need to go
ah here we are
yes ooh pink slime perfect exactly what
I needed for my traditional British
decorations got a knife got a door got a
pig oh this is where they came from whoo
this where they emerge from their portal
there anything here that I need any
secrets any goodie goodies any tiny box
Sims no just massive boxes that I don't
care about now say it I don't care who
hears it all right one note and then we
off we go I watched as a lamb opened the
first of the seals I heard one of the
four living creatures say with a voice
like thunder calm then I looked and
there was a white horse that emerge from
the portal its rider had a bowl it was
given a crown and rode off as a warrior
to win battles
what kind of battles are you talking
about
I read that already you were diving
deeper into the mystery of the story I
always like you want a good one
the secret wattles power lies within the
four globes or the orbs of pestilence
famine death
if I am to close the portal I must
collect each or remove them from the
quarter but I have all four oars
I can close the port Rance escape will
be noodles okay so we're going on a
self-sacrificing mission is that how
that's gonna be I see
so do I need to cross through the portal
in order later to give the a break in
order to get these things close this off
is that what I need to do is that my
understanding here all right then bring
it on you bastards I'm ready
God who would build this castle right
here exactly where it didn't need to
move that's pretty oh that is really
pretty you know even though there's a
lot of next generation graphical stuff
going on occasionally this game surprise
to me and it actually is very very
pretty I do like it and we're in the
water the water is freezing she's not
staying here for any longer than
necessary why will it kill me
yeah okay then where do I need to go
that place is barred off let's just take
this
yeah I'm gonna freeze apparently yeah
okay yeah got it
okay don't know where this is taking me
but I'm blindly following the path that
I first go down that's high I'm sorry
were you naked this is the bathroom am i
coming out of the poop hole okay excuse
me stop humping that and we'll be on our
way okay my character seems to have a
proclivity to go right exactly where he
doesn't want to go but I don't know what
to expect from this ah damn it I didn't
get the oil from the last one okay so
that's for hiding just in case the guy
runs down here and decides to nibble my
giblets and the lamb opened the third
seal I heard the third living creature
say come I looked and there was a black
horse and his rider how to scale I heard
what sounded like a voice from among the
four living creatures saying a quarter
of wheat for a day's pay a three quarts
of barley for a day's pay but do not
damage the olive oil and the wine that's
an odd thing to proclaim as soon as you
exit your weird portal
well hello there is that the sound of a
moose man coming from down this hole are
you gonna shout come at me okay then I
was probably a bad thing alright
everything seems to be fine okay we're
water monster territory I know this I
know this don't you go gurgle blob at me
no really I could have sworn I heard a
gurgle blob like this why would you just
put body parts strewn about if you
didn't want me to throw them in the
water all would
okay thanks Bob perhaps I could find a
way to scale the pipes really I'm
talking very calmly about this all all
the worst things in the world are likely
having
why was that I just heard you ain't
gonna kill me now this time he's son of
a [ __ ]
I've done worse than this I can climb up
here it ain't no thing I think it's
gonna let me find the pipes it's it uh
how would I do that how would I do that
damn it's gotta find a way to climb the
Oh up there okay I got it
okay so I need something else huh I
don't know effective alright alright
that it was nothing it was a whole lotta
nothin ain't nothing it ain't nothing
would you gasps bad I didn't see
anything
gust okay I'm - I like it
not a lot need more
here we go
some sometimes the pipes require
maintenance to ensure they stay in
working order a system has been
installed and can be used to redirect
the water float in the mansion above to
do this the levers must be used
correctly to change with pipes direct
the water for the levers must remain
stationary all pressure will get too
high and reset all the letters you dokie
then I will try what did that do aha
okay so these two are correct shouldn't
be standing in the darkness but it's ah
there we go that's what I needed
ah crap poopy not that one either
I did it I solved the incredibly complex
puzzle now I can climb the pipes wander
my way into freedom sure hope I don't
fall off these pipes somehow and then
get thrown into the water pull long
you're gonna do that aren't you game
you're gonna do that to me you're gonna
do this all right
don't talk don't laugh I don't it
seriously I will give you anything I'll
give you my prize bread collection I
don't know I'm not thinking straight
don't do it don't do it right there when
I'm so close stand on the ledge I think
it's gonna be fine
oh my god are you serious you're not
gonna do it oh [ __ ] I thought for sure
they were gonna do it what the hell God
disappointed that they didn't aah
the horsemen defend their realm with the
greatest weapon of all their victims all
nine so am I in the realm or am I not in
the realm just yet
okey-dokey then
well charge forward blindly into the
realm of the okay water again cuz how I
love thee I thought the water part was
over I kind of got that idea from the
whole
I don't why ok nap time again huh why do
you ignore me I don't know come closer
please I know bad ideas what I see them
don't know what trickery this is but
you're not who I think you are you come
me it is me your daughter okay Oh
Catherine oh let's hold off on that
whomever you are you're not the person I
perceive you to be right and you're not
who you say you are very good please
come to me I drank of you up maybe it's
good idea maybe I should go for it hey
it seems good what else could I possibly
do Wow can't go backwards so I guess
this is actually happening now we just
get a rock ready to throw it someone
just in case you're a little more
monstery okay nap time again in the
let's go over there I'm gonna carry this
with me just in case ya stay in case I
had a feeling you are all squiggly and
God
I dropped my rock somewhere here god
damn it I can't get to it
that was my rock here we go here we go
we're fine okay so apparently I clamp
jump off on something if I got a rock in
my hand okay we're good we're good we're
good we're good all right we're fine I
think I see stairs over there
good good good we're fine we're fine
we're fine get out of here and afraid of
you no more haven't been afraid of you
since 2013
all right this looks possibly and Val V
no maybe not thingy what no hey you're
go there's another thingy all right
we're good okay thunk it e thunk who's
got junk
cuz of all these boxes in no tiny box
Tim I miss him but good thing he's right
here with me y'all always have my little
bit skinnier I've been seeing pictures
of this crop up all over the place this
is the most adorable thing that could've
possibly oh god it's Long Island hey so
I just ran out of oil well sorry about
tiny bucks still well yes that's a thing
that happens that's good I'm glad well
then all right who do we have why is
this blocked up I kind of want to know
what's in there but at the same time
maybe god I thought I was done with the
water why do I keep returning to the
water I know I'd rather not
okay that's creepy what am i what is the
point of this don't tell me you just
sent me to oh I get it plate pi PI pi PI
pi PI pi PI gotta gotta get there
getting it got it I got it
five P pike this goes over here that
bypasses that gate over there
and I'm in trouble aren't I you're gonna
do that thing I didn't want you to do
huh oh I gotta do that thing I didn't
want to do all right well there's been
fun living is not as cool as I thought
it is so here I go
Hey
push
son of a biscuit not malinov escape
in my ears there we go that's the thing
I jump over that please tell me I can
yes I can oh here we go whoo I found it
all right you son of a [ __ ] hey think
you can mess with me manses probably not
all right so anyway that seems like a
good place to stop as any so I'm gonna
play through this whole game as quick as
I can maybe do it all today I have no
idea but I know there's already gonna be
a good one it's tense it's got a good
story good voice acting custom items
it's got all the makings of a great
story so I hope you guys are enjoying it
I'll get the next part out as soon as I
can thank you all so much for watching
and if you want to check out tons of
more amnesia custom stories that I've
done in the past in the description
below you'll find a huge list of custom
stories and in the annotations at the
end slate you'll see a bunch more so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
oh sure okay I'm not going down there
ever oh god damn it
no make